nice to see oh I'm so excited to be back
in Toronto I I landed here and I just
felt at home I really fell in love with
the city and got to explore it so much
when we were filming Little Italy so I'm
really excited to be back and I hope to
come back more often I mean it's
gorgeous yeah I mean I've always loved
romantic comedies you know people are
saying romantic comedies are back and
I'm like well judging by my Netflix
queue they never left like all I have on
there are old romantic comedies so I I'm
so excited to be a part of one and I
hope I get to do more I realized when I
got here today that I haven't told her
about this movie so I have to call her
all-in-all you know anything on my pizza
anything while we were filming this
movie I ate so much pizza I had no
vegetables unless they were on a pizza
so that's uh that's how far my toppings
went to get me the right nutrition on
top of the overload of pizza I ate I'm
so excited to be back on American Horror
Story and this year is apocalypse and it
is I have to say the craziest season yet
just with the crossovers and the people
coming back as past characters and to
get all the witches from coven together
including Stevie Nicks
it was insane I mean it was Saturday
night and Stevie Nicks was singing for
us I I really almost dropped dead I mean
I I just stood in awe because I'm I'm
Stevie Nicks biggest fan and and she
she's doing a show at the end of the
year and I definitely like totally just
asked for tickets
Splatt out I'm like can I come thank you